muy buenos días si a ustedes les
pregunto cuál fue el último evento
geológico con potencial destructor que
se recuerda en la península ibérica'
serían capaz de decirme solamente uno
muy probablemente no seguramente algunas
personas recordarán el terremoto de
lorca del año 2011 como un evento con
potencial destructor
pero si a todo el mundo le enseño esta
imagen por satélite es sacada de 'google
earth' seguramente sean capaces de
reconocer que ven en la imagen es el el
estadio santiago bernabéu que tenemos
apenas unos metros de aquí que quiero
decir con un estadio como el santiago
bernabéu bueno quiero decir lo siguiente
cada año mueren 40.000 personas en
eventos geológicos en eventos
potencialmente destructores esto quiere
decir que cada año que perdón cada dos
años muere suficiente es suficiente
gente como para llenar el santiago
bernabéu esto es una cifra realmente
inimaginable y realmente terrible de
hecho hay años realmente trágicos y
realmente terribles en los cuales mueren
cinco veces la capacidad del santiago
bernabéu en tan solo un evento geológico
por ejemplo creo que todos recordarán el
terremoto de sumatra del año 2004 o el
terremoto de haití del año 2010 que fue
muy destructor murieron 200.000 personas
en apenas unas horas un terremoto como
el del tíbet que mató a más de 80.000
personas en apenas unos minutos no sólo
por el terremoto sino por todos los
fenómenos asociados
que sólo recoge los juegos que vamos a
tratar hoy hay tres riesgos geológicos
principales de los que vamos a hablar
hoy que son los que más muertes causan
en el mundo especialmente en zonas
vulnerables en países en vías de
desarrollo y en el tercer mundo
en primer lugar tenemos los desastres
geológicos relacionados con los volcanes
los volcanes muchísimas veces lo
relacionamos con estas aberturas que
aparecen en la superficie de la tierra
que lanza el lava incandescente que
muchas veces son incluso turísticas y
visitables pero no todo se reduce a eso
hay muchísimos fenómenos como la caída
de ceniza por ejemplo o los lajares que
son inmensas colas de barro que son
capaces de arrasar grandes zonas del
territorio en apenas unos minutos luego
tenemos los fenómenos sísmicos que son
los terremotos en españa por ejemplo
tenemos muchísima suerte aunque es una
zona sísmicamente de una actividad
moderada en los últimos en las últimas
décadas no hemos tenido ningún terremoto
destructor aparte del de lorca y que fue
de una magnitud muy moderada y que
desgraciadamente tuvo los efectos que
todo el mundo conoce pues por cuestiones
muy concretas especialmente relacionadas
por la construcción y por el lugar donde
ocurrió
y por supuesto también tenemos los
deslizamientos los deslizamientos son
uno de los fenómenos geológicos menos
conocidos pero son uno de los más
mortíferos estos ocurren en la ladera de
las montañas cuando una gran cantidad de
material baja ladera abajo y es capaz de
arrasar pues grandes cantidades de
superficie cerrar carreteras e incluso
llegar a cubrir pueblos enteros esto es
una cosa que muy poca gente conoce pero
que realmente ocurre en el mundo y que
es capaz de causar una gran destrucción
y una gran mortalidad
uno de los grandes problemas a los que
nos enfrentamos en el siglo 21 y que
eran inimaginables de poder resolver
hace unos años es la predicción de estos
fenómenos con un tiempo suficiente como
para evacuar o mitigar sus efectos pero
qué entendemos por predicción hoy en día
si alguien me pregunta si somos capaces
de poder predecir cualquier desastre
geológico por ejemplo para hoy a las 4
de la tarde le diré que hoy por hoy es
imposible sé que muchísimas veces
después de que ocurra un evento de este
tipo sale muchísima gente de los medios
de comunicación diciendo que lo habían
predicho pero eso hoy por hoy no es
cierto de hecho hoy por hoy la
predicción se limita a un número de
posibilidades de que ocurra un evento
hecho un evento dado en los próximos
años es decir por ejemplo hoy hay un 30
por ciento de posibilidades de que
ocurra un terremoto de una magnitud dada
en este lugar eso evidentemente no es
suficiente alerta como para poder
evacuar una población o para poder tomar
medidas que sean capaces de corregirlo
pero estamos cada vez más en el camino
certero para poder empezar a hacer
predicciones con una mayor fiabilidad
perdón que se han pasado las
diapositivas
hoy día estamos prediciendo con
muchísima fiabilidad las erupciones
volcánicas porque porque desde hace unos
años somos capaces de medir con
muchísima precisión antes de que ocurra
nada cómo cambia la forma de un volcán
cuando la lava está encendiendo por la
corteza terrestre y está empezando a
deformar la tierra somos capaces de
medir los gases que emiten los volcanes
antes de que empiece la erupción somos
capaces de medir la temperatura que
tienen los arroyos relacionados con
estos volcanes y somos capaces de medir
muchísimas cosas pero incluso aún así a
veces tenemos problemas con la
predicción de los volcanes porque a
pesar de que los volcanes podemos verlo
y podemos ver muchísimas de las señales
que emiten a veces nos equivocamos y
aquí les dejo dos ejemplos muy recientes
el primero que hay a la izquierda no sé
si recordarán que hace apenas un mes en
indonesia hubo la erupción de un volcán
del volcán taal bueno pues los
científicos fueron capaces de dar a
tiempo la voz de alarma y de empezar a
evacuar las poblaciones cercanas para
evitar que la calidad de ceniza
provocará pues muerte bien por el
derrumbamiento de los techos porque el
peso de la ceniza hace que muchísimas
casas colapsen o bien por los problemas
respiratorios
pero sin embargo en diciembre del pasado
año nueva zelanda una erupción volcánica
en un volcán en una isla que se llama
white island al norte de nueva zelanda y
que mató a 20 personas que pudo pasar
para que una cosa fuera predecible y la
otra no pues realmente no lo sabemos
todavía hay muchísimas cosas que por
desgracia se nos escapan a la hora de
predecir los riesgos volcánicos pero
podemos ver como ya hay casos en los que
somos capaces de predecirlo aunque
todavía hay algunos que se nos escapen
luego tenemos los deslizamientos los
deslizamientos son realmente terribles
porque muchísimas veces ocurren en los
extrarradios de las ciudades más pobres
del mundo en zonas muy lluviosas y donde
las laderas son muy inestables pero
gracias a los satélites más modernos
somos capaces de empezar a medir cómo se
mueven las laderas de todo nuestro
planeta prácticamente a diario somos
capaces de ver los deslizamientos más
pequeños de apenas milímetros y de dar
una señal de alarma cuando empezamos a
ver cómo esta ladera comienza a moverse
hacia abajo cuál es el problema que
todavía hoy no somos capaces de poder
analizar todas las laderas del mundo
simultáneamente porque se requiere un
gran poder de computación muchísimos
ordenadores trabajando simultáneamente
pero poco a poco lo estamos consiguiendo
y la nasa de hecho en los últimos años
ha desarrollado un modelo para predecir
dónde podrían ocurrir a tiempo real este
tipo de deslizamientos usando datos como
por ejemplo la precipitación el uso del
suelo si tiene cobertura vegetal pero
desgraciadamente estos modelos todavía
no funcionan para hacer una predicción
temporal
y a veces incluso avisan después de que
haya ocurrido porque todavía no
conocemos muy bien este tipo de
fenómenos cómo funcionan y que los
desencadenan
de hecho en españa en las últimas
semanas hemos tenido un evento de
deslizamiento que mató a dos
trabajadores en un vertedero del país
vasco' concretamente en el municipio de
saldívar creo que todo el mundo lo
recordará bueno pues quizá si hubiésemos
tenido ya la capacidad de análisis
suficiente como para poder analizar a
tiempo real todas las laderas del mundo
incluso esta ladera que en realidad una
ladera artificial porque era de un
vertedero quizá se podría haber dado la
señal de alarma de una manera automática
y haber evitado esta catástrofe humana
que ha costado la vida de dos personas
además de numerosos daños materiales en
la autovía
y por último tenemos quizá uno de los
eventos destructores a nivel geológico
más importantes que son los terremotos
los terremotos son uno de los eventos
más destructores que ocurren por una
razón principal primero porque afectan a
una gran cantidad de terreno a un
territorio muy grande
por supuesto porque también ocurren
muchísimas veces en zonas donde la
calidad de la construcción es muy mala
en zonas pues muy pobres y que por lo
tanto afectan a muchísima más gente
además los terremotos en muchísimos
lugares son capaces de venir acompañados
por el tsunami lo que encima amplifica
el potencial destructor de estos eventos
geológicos
pero en los últimos años estamos
avanzando muchísimo gracias a los
ordenadores y al uso de la inteligencia
artificial
los terremotos emiten una serie de
vibraciones que se dan cuando la corteza
terrestre se rompe y empieza a vibrar
bueno pues que estamos haciendo ahora
ahora gracias al uso de la inteligencia
artificial lo que estamos haciendo es
romper rocas estamos sometiendo a rocas
a muy alta presión a torsión las estamos
haciendo sufrir y estamos escuchando
como estas rocas se parten y se agrietan
qué interés puede tener el escuchar cómo
se rompe o se agrieta una roca bueno
pues estamos intentando reconocer cuáles
son los sonidos y las vibraciones que
emiten estas rocas justo en el momento
antes de romperse
con todos esos datos nosotros empezamos
a ser capaces de empezar a escuchar
señales precursoras de los terremotos y
que nos permitan hacer una predicción es
cierto que estas investigaciones llevan
apenas dos años haciéndose pero ya
empezamos a tener resultados fiables ya
empezamos a entrenar las inteligencias
artificiales para que sean capaces de
reconocer estos patrones que antes eran
totalmente imperceptibles y de hecho en
este perdón en el año 2019 ya empezamos
a enseñar a una inteligencia artificial
a escuchar todo el catálogo de los
terremotos que han ocurrido en nuestro
planeta para ver si es capaz de
reconocer en este caso a posteriori las
señales precursoras de un terremoto y
una vez entrenada con una con un grado
suficiente de fiabilidad ver si podemos
extrapolar este modelo a futuro y si
efectivamente como nosotros pensamos los
terremotos se producen de una manera
relativamente similar que nos permita
que nos permita producir una predicción
certera y poder avisar a las poblaciones
que están en un mayor riesgo pues de
sufrir un terremoto destructor
de una manera parecida a la que por
ejemplo cuando vemos una canción escrita
sobre un pentagrama y vemos unas notas
de música es decir nosotros intentamos
reconocer estos patrones intentamos
continuar los de tal manera que sepamos
cuándo va a llegar esa nota que sería el
terremoto y poder dar la señal de aviso
y esto es fundamental porque gracias a
todas estas nuevas tecnologías vamos a
poder evitar muchísimas muertes en el
mundo especialmente en países en vías de
desarrollo
de hecho para que se hagan una idea de
la dificultad de la predicción sísmica
que supone hoy en día uno de los mejores
modelos que hay de predicción de
terremotos es el modelo norteamericano
este que ven en la pantalla como mucho
es capaz de darnos la probabilidad de
que ocurra un terremoto de magnitud 6 o
de magnitud 7 en california en los
próximos 30 años es decir imagínense la
fiabilidad que tuviese que salir es el
hombre del tiempo en la televisión y
dijese que dentro de 30 años o de aquí
dentro de 30 años podría llover no
tendría ninguna verdad bueno pues hoy en
día lo mejor en modelos están llegando a
este nivel pero pensamos que en los
próximos años gracias al desarrollo de
la inteligencia artificial van a mejorar
muchísimo y vamos a hacer a poder hacer
predicciones muy fiables
hace 200 años aproximadamente ocurrió la
fundación de la geología moderna tal y
como la conocemos y uno de los padres de
la geología tras la hiel dijo que el
presente era la clave del pasado porque
con lo que estaba ocurriendo hoy en día
sobre nuestro planeta podíamos entender
el pasado el pasado que estaba escrito
en el registro geológico en las rocas en
los fósiles en los minerales pero hoy
pensamos que quizás esto era todavía muy
poco porque todavía no tenía las
herramientas suficientes pensamos que
todavía se podría añadir un poco más y
pensamos que el pasado en realidad es la
clave del futuro que intentando escuchar
cómo se rompe las rocas hoy o cómo se
han roto con todo este registro que
tenemos intentando entender cómo han
funcionado los deslizamientos en otro
modelo o cómo han comenzado las
soluciones volcánicas y qué señales ha
habido nosotros vamos a poder hacer
modelos que sean capaces de predecir los
riesgos sísmicos y así ayudar a salvar
las vidas de muchísimas personas muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]